so I'd now like to present our presenter
Pam Hines Pam Hines is professor and
director of the Center on work
technology and organization in the
department of management science and
engineering she studies the effect in
technology on teams in collaboration pam
has conducted extensive research on the
dynamics of cross boundary work teams
and teams particularly those spanning
national borders
she's also published extensively on the
relationship between national culture
and work practices particularly
exploring how work practices are
technology created in one location are
understood and employed at distant sites
pamela also has a body of research on
human robot interaction in the work
environment and the dynamics of human
robot teams most recently pamela has
been looking at the changing nature of
work in the face of emerging
technologies including the nature of
coordination in open innovation changes
in work and organic organizing results
from 3d printing and the work of data
analysts with that i'll turn it over to
you pam right thank you so much Megan so
in this webinar we're going to talk as
Megan said about how to lead and not
just survive digital transformation
we're going to discuss some of the
critical factors for digital
transformation and in particular those
foundational aspects the differentiate
organizations that are prepared and more
likely to be successful and taking
advantage of the opportunities that
digital technologies provide so first
what I want to do is talk about what
digital transformation is there are
actually a number of different
definitions out there first one is from
Salesforce they say that it is the
process of using digital technologies to
create new or modify existing business
processes culture and customer
experiences to meet changing business
and market requirements it's a fairly
all-encompassing definition which allows
for more modest as well as more dramatic
change within the organization the
second definition is one by George
Westerman who's a research scientist at
MIT Mesa
it's a radical rethinking of how an
organization uses technology people and
processes the fundamentally change
business performance so this is a little
bit more narrow definition which focus
is more on radically rethinking and
fundamentally changing the business the
third one from Gartner is more narrow
yet they argue that it is about
exploiting digital technologies and
supporting capabilities to create a
robust new digital business model so
this is a little bit more narrow because
it's really focused on changing the
business model rather than for example
just internal processes for this course
my definition is closer to the last two
I think its digital transformation is
really more than just minor changes
minor tweaking within the organization
but transformational in that we're
talking about radically rethinking
optimize your business model and
fundamentally changing how business is
done I also want to point out that in
all of these definitions we're talking
about the entire business we're not
talking about you know just changing
finance or just changing manufacturing
it's really the entire organization that
ends up getting touched by digital
transformation we'll talk more about
that later evidence from the World
Economic Forum and others suggests that
investing in new business models is
probably the most difficult and
certainly the most frequently targeted
within organizations across industries
and this is important because it
requires significant cultural change in
order to make that kind of a dramatic
transformation so I also want to talk a
little bit about the emerging
technologies that we're referring to
when we talk about digital
transformation oftentimes in the same
breath we're going to do digital
transformation and these emerging
disruptive kinds of technologies those
technologies are going to be most likely
to shake up businesses and shake up
industries so let's go down the list
here on the top
right-hand or left-hand corner rather
with the Internet of Things and that
refers to any physical device which can
be connected to the Internet but isn't
used to directly access the web like
smart phones or computers the analyst
firm Gartner says that by 2020 there
will be over 26 billion connected
devices everything from refrigerators to
cars activity sensors medical monitoring
and a whole host of other applications
then we've got autonomous vehicles and
drones that can move people and things
around without necessarily having a
human driver or controller down
we've got robotics and robotics operate
in all host of domains including
industrial robots manufacturing settings
but also in the home and operating rooms
in the fields picking apples and so on
and so forth some of these may be more
economist some of them less so but we're
seeing a lot of robotics out there 3d
printing is also anticipated to be a
disrupting technology and could
potentially radically change
manufacturing and where parts end up
getting made around the world a I that's
the one that we hear about most often
and of course there are numerous
applications on to AI and we'll talk
about a few examples of the course of
the webinar big data data analytics and
cloud also really important discuss
really frequently and we'll talk about
that a bit more as well virtual reality
and augmented reality that's a
technology that is still developing and
it's not quite clear exactly what all
the applications of that may end up
being the photograph on this slide is a
virtual reality being used to train
employees to be more empathic and that
is one of the applications that we're
beginning to see out there is training
and giving people this more immersive
experience so that they're training
is more effective then of course we've
got digital traceability and blockchain
which is being discussed quite a bit and
social media and platforms which have
been out there for quite some time but
can make a huge difference in terms of
the information that's available and who
the information is shared with and how
although AI gets a lot of the attention
all of these technologies have been
identified as potential disruptors to
products to companies and to industries
the Internet of Things for example is
already being used or water supply
management in rice fields in Malaysia
and as magic fans at Disney which allows
park goers at Disneyland to manage their
entire park experience through a band
that they wear on their wrist so one
question that we often get asked is how
is the disruption that we're
anticipating today different than in the
past with personal computers smartphones
and so forth and there are number of
things that we believe are different one
is just the pace and velocity of change
Krieger at the World Economic Forum
argued that it took 75 years for 100
million people to get access to the
telephone and yet the gaming app Pokemon
go hook that many users in less than one
month and 2016 so just really really
rapid adoption of these technologies the
number of patents related to these
technologies brew at a rate of 54
percent from 2015 to 2017 so again you
know just the pace the velocity of
change both in terms of invention and
adoption are really outstanding and
unprecedented another difference is the
holistic nature many of these
technologies
combined to offer products services and
change business models when combined
after combining AI and robotics for
example or combining the Internet of
Things this often combined with AI with
data analytics and so forth and these
combinations tend to unleash
capabilities that can exceed what is
possible when they're deployed
separately and certainly exceed what we
have seen before data is also a huge
aspect here of what is different as I'm
sure most of you all of you know there
are just vast amounts of data out there
readily available about customer
behavior customer preferences employee
behaviors behaviors of machines and so
forth there's just a ton of information
that can be scraped that is available to
organizations that can be stored and we
now have computational approaches that
allow us to deal with these huge
quantities of data in order to analyze
and rapidly adjust products and services
and products that we want to offer and
then finally flows of information and
this is large part because of social
networks data can flow much more easily
often outside the control of the
organization where information gets put
out there by customers by suppliers and
so forth and that can go viral
it can affect stock prices it can affect
customer attitudes toward what it is an
organization is offering so with back
reap introduction we've got another poll
and what I'd like to know is what your
experience is if your experience is so
think about the industry that you're in
and consider how one or more of these
technologies might disrupt that industry
so give you a minute to complete that
poll
okay so it looks like the vast majority
of you believe that there is going to be
a really significant disruption in your
industry and I think that really drives
with some of the research that has been
done a similar question was asked by
Gary Kane and his colleagues in a recent
book that came out the technology that I
see
came out a few months ago and one of the
things that they did was they surveyed
about 4,000 leaders and employees and
variety of industries and as you can see
from this slide about 87 percent
anticipated at least moderate digital
disruption and 59 percent expected rate
digital disruption according to the
World Economic Forum most industries are
going to be heavily affected and that
includes aviation travel and tourism
chemistry advanced materials mining and
metals oil and gas professional services
retail telecom automotive electricity
healthcare logistics media financial
services and so on and so forth
you know point being that very few
industries if any are going to be immune
from this digital disruption and that's
another change from past trends in the
past what we saw is that you know an
industry or a subset of industries might
be affected by the introduction of a new
technology and with the technologies
today that we're seeing they're just
really widespread here's another the
results of another survey survey item
from Kane and colleagues and this one
they asked people to the extent to which
they agreed that their organization is
adequately preparing for these district
actions and as you can see only about
44% believe that their organizations are
adequately preparing and multiple
studies multiple articles bear this out
so people are generally expecting a huge
shift huge disruption and yet most
people are feeling like their
organizations their industries are
inadequately prepared to deal with the
disruption for this on its way here's
another chart that was in the book
leading digital by George Westermann and
his colleagues and one of the things
that they did is they looked at what
they called digital masters and to do
masters organizations where they have
both the leadership to carry out these
changes in the digital capabilities to
carry out these changes and as you can
see from this chart banking height act
insurance a little bit lesser extent
seemed to have a heart higher percentage
of digital masters than for example
pharmaceuticals utilities and to some
extent consumer packaged goods so there
is variance in industries in terms of
their level of preparation so what does
digital transformation look like within
an organization one thing is new
efficiencies so a lot of people talk
about just using these technologies to
do things faster to do things better to
reduce numbers of errors and so forth
one example of that is Siemens they
digitized some major electronics plant
in Germany a few years ago to the extent
that it was 75% automated as a result of
deploying these technologies that
increase their output by a factor of 10
significantly decreased defects and
increase the speed of production so
really getting a lot of advantage out of
that transformation better customer
experience
that's another goal of most digital
transformation efforts
and the hope is to deploy products and
services that customers enjoy more and
build customer loyalty and support one
example there is a Marriott hotel chain
they have been able to personalize the
entire travel journey using extensive
customer data they even have a I powered
BOTS for mostly for their more
technologically savvy customers but the
Box enabled people to for example change
reservations and so forth much more
easily and what they've reported is that
they're seeing an increase in customer
loyalty and also increases in market
share and attribute that to the advances
that they're making using these
technologies now doing business in this
business differently is when we're
really beginning to talk about more
fundamental business model changes one
way to think about this is it's a matter
of paying attention to what is out there
what's going on in the market what the
technologies are and using that
information to disrupt your industry
from within not waiting for Airbnb uber
and so forth to execute the disruption
for you one example is DHL their
logistics company shipping things around
the globe and one of the things that
they noticed is that 3d printing is
likely to come on the scene and to the
extent that it does in in a big way
anyway it will disrupt logistics it will
disrupt the need to move products as
they happen in the past so as a result
they're incorporating Kirby printing
into their core services in a sense
internally disrupting the logistics
industry generally continual innovation
when we look at organizations that are
successful in digital transformation we
see continual innovation they've set
themselves up
as an innovation company and have
innovation forward cultures and then the
last one in some ways is the most
important and that is we haven't talked
about digital transformation as as if
you go from state a to state B and in
fact it's not that that discrete new
years the French essentially looking at
a continuous dynamic process there is no
state B there is no end goal the idea is
that it's really about digitally
transforming and having an organization
a foundation that supports this kind of
constant change so those are the
organizations that are most successful
in in achieving digital transformation
or digital transforming you know the
ghaib foundation and they are prepared
for this ongoing dynamic change okay so
we've got one last poll here so my
question to you is given all of this
that we've been talking about what's
required in your opinion for digitally
transforming and I'd asked you to check
just the top three and it's not that the
others aren't important but I'd like you
to really prioritize what would you
focus on first
okay hopefully everyone's had a chance
to respond here so of course all of
these are required but perhaps to
varying degrees and in different
sequences depending on where you're at
we tend to hear a lot more about access
to digital talent and having an
architecture that supports access and
integration of data so that you can
actually deliver business value of
course these are critical and they
support these credits and services well
we also need a digital culture we also
need some of these organizational
aspects okay so I'm gonna move on and it
isn't as much about the technology as we
might think and that's one of the things
I'm hoping that you'll take away from
the webinar today is that it's not just
a pure focus on the technology but it
requires an understanding of digital
trends and technology as well as some of
these organizational aspects changes to
culture and practice so here a few
quotes from the cane a tall book this is
not about the tools but the ability to
operate effectively in an environment
dominated by those tools Rogers in his
book the digital transformation playbook
says digital transformation is not about
the technology it's about strategy and
new ways of thinking in an HBR article
or in chippewa say you know it's really
a myth that digital is about the
technology Westerman in a Sloan
management review article says that
digital isn't the answer
transformation is really what we should
be focusing on and anything more extreme
view in an article in the kinsey
quarterly caitlin and colleagues say
yeah well template
technical capabilities are crucial a
strong and adaptive culture can actually
help make up for the lack of them so you
know too much focus on technology the
evidence suggests in distract the
business from focusing on the vision of
what a transformed business needs to
look like and what that means for
customers so you know really keeping a
focus you know having that that
technology background having the
technology talent is critical but we
also really need to keep focused on
building an organization that can
support the development of the
innovation that's required this is a
another study that was done this is
actually a survey of 25 industry and
research consulting panelists across a
variety - interest industries other
things that was interesting about this
is these are really experienced people
so they had on average a little under
ten years of experience in digital
transformation and for the most part
they held senior positions like CEO
chief digital officer and so forth and
now this suggests only and the numbers
here are the percentage of panelists who
selected this item as one of the top 10
choices as being important for
successful digital transformation and as
you can see a lot of these values of it
they've identified really get to the
culture of the organization so open this
toward change focusing on the customer
being willing to learn innovation
agility knowledge sharing attitude
toward value of cooperation and so forth
so what I've done is I've pursed it a
little bit differently but capture all
of what was in that last chart that we
saw and distilled sort of what is in the
research and what the opinions of
experts have been who are leading these
digital
transformations and I'm focusing on
these five items and in the center you
have customer-centric and that's in the
center because all of these capabilities
are employed in service of providing
customer value oftentimes through new
business models but just in general you
know this focus on the customer as a way
of leveraging these new technologies
with customer centered as a starting
point of the other organization
organizational factors lay the
groundwork for digital transforming
including being fast and nimble being
able to move quickly to identify and act
on these opportunities voracious
learning you're really focusing on
figuring out what you don't know and
learning new things unbound
collaboration you know one of things
that we're seeing is that a lot of
collaboration of particular
collaboration across boundaries that is
much more fluid is an indicator of
success for these organizations that are
digitally transforming and having an
appetite for risk so being willing to
take risks to fail and to try again so
having to unlearn a learning centric
culture a culture that is moving fast
where you can take the risk
we've got unbounded collaboration are
all intended to really support the
development of these new capabilities
and of course these are all overlapping
you know these there's a reason that I
have all of these together in one
diagram all of them sort of feed on and
support one another a little bit more on
the customer centric piece on Westerman
in his book leading digital points out
but there are four things that digital
masters tend to do to transform the
customer experience
one is importantly they design
customer experience from the outside in
meaning that they really kind of step
back and look from the customers
experience they're taking the customers
perspective and they are empathizing
with the interests the preferences and
the needs of customers and then they're
designing from that standpoint as
opposed to what you know we sometimes
traditionally done which is develop a
new technology or develop a new product
and then figure out how we might get
that out to a particular customer base
another thing that digital masters do to
transform the customer experience is to
increase reach and engagement these
because these companies are really out
there engaging with customers really
trying to understand what they care
about and talking with them the third
thing that Western identified is putting
customer data at the heart of the
experience so really gathering this data
that are available on what customers are
doing what it is that customers prefer
what their patterns are and so forth and
then using that as a way to improve the
experience so there's a really nice
example with Airbnb where they use data
and algorithms to provide pricing tips
to hosts so that host can get more
bookings so they pay attention on a
day-to-day basis what customers tend to
do and then based on that help the hosts
understand how they might want to drop
or increase their prices in order to
maximize the number of people who stay
in there Aaron Airbnb and the prices
that they're getting and then finally
seamlessly meshing the digital and
physical experience this is something
again that digital masters do for
example Burberry they have done an
excellent job of bringing digital into
the retail experience they have
something called a retail theater
concept so if you go into
one of these Burberry stores you can
actually watch runway shows live in the
store and if you see something that you
really like you can actually order it
via an iPad so they blended this digital
and in-store experience and created an
online experience that really gives you
the feel of Burberry so there's a very
narrow line between the intense tour
experience and the online experience
it's like coming into Burberry's world
turns out that more people actually see
the Burberry brand be a digital than
through any other medium these days and
they've been rated as fast companies top
10 most innovative retail companies as a
result of the transformation that
they've demonstrated okay so I'm going
to go into a little bit more detail on
the time that we have on nimble and fast
and also unbounded collaboration so
let's start by talking about being
nimble and fast so nimbleness and
agility generally referred to being able
to act and react quickly to assess and
then rapidly adapt to new situations
changes in the market changes in
technology and so forth and those
organizations that are successful in
digitally transforming tend to be very
agile very nimble what why is that
important for digital transformation
well the base have changed as we talked
about before requires really a constant
rethinking of direction and pivoting
some evidence suggests that you know a
few years is about the most that a
company can continue with any one
direction with no changes and still be
viable and in some cases it's going to
need to be even more frequent than that
so of course it's important for digital
transformation part of that is scanning
the environment identifying hazards
identifying opportunities formulating
strategic initiative
in order to go after those opportunities
and then of course an organization has
to be able to implement these new ideas
to be able to very quickly pivot quickly
change from offering one product or
service to offering another product or
service and that's one of the places
that you know digital masters or
organizations they're really successful
at doing this really excel and
differentiate themselves so it's really
about speed and it's about innovation so
how do you design for nimbleness one is
having an organizational structure that
really promotes nimbleness many of us
have a lot of experience with
traditional hierarchies and hierarchies
were designed in order to be reliable
efficient but not necessarily to be
quick and as a result now these
traditional hierarchies are breaking
down and they need to be broken down to
some extent so that people can work with
those that they need to work with in
order to really get things done often
agile organizations are structured as
fluid squads that are loosely connected
based on the customer needs our
particular project initiatives and their
interdependencies so much more fluid
structure that can change rapidly
business processes important to think
about how projects enter and activities
are organized and managed you know we're
come gone are the days of a really
extensive long term detailed project
plans in favour of Sprint's or other
short time frames to rapidly ask
experiment get feedback adjust and then
continue on oftentimes their daily
stand-up meetings frequent
communications and so forth in order to
be able to want a line across the
business systems also need to
allow for this fluidity for example
through the sharing of information
across these squads or teams pushing
down decision-making to the lowest
possible level enable to to enable rapid
action
it also requires systems that provide
information at those lower levels which
is much more possible these days than it
has been in the past and we need leaders
organizations that are successful at
doing this have leaders that see
themselves as enabling others rather
than directing so micromanagement and
digital transformation are really not
very compatible because you need people
to be able to see what needs to be done
and do it and be trusted to move forward
and all of this is sustained by clear
vision and priorities and that's when
the crucial leadership roles and has
pointed out by many experts and a lot of
research on digital transformation is
it's crucial that you'd have a clear
vision so that everybody knows the
direction that they're moving and they
can make decisions and come up with
these ideas and meet customer needs in a
way that's aligned with that so it's
really about sort of steering the ship
in a particular direction and letting
everybody know that ok so I'm going to
talk just for a couple minutes here
about unbounded collaboration unbounded
collaboration as I sort of alluded to
earlier the general consensus is that
digital transformation requires
extensive collaboration across
boundaries including functional
boundaries expertise organizational
boundaries often times sometimes
geographies and so forth and
collaboration unlike in decades past
needs to be much more fluid so any
Edmonson the Harvard came up with this
idea of teaming versus teams to describe
this ongoing process of collaborating
with people as needed on a given project
so one of the reasons that this is so
important for digital transformation is
because diversity is said to be a key
driver for innovation and innovation is
central to digital transformation and we
hear this from multiple sources that
without diversity teams and
organizations you can't get there there
was a study that was done by Forbes with
that three hundred and twenty or so
executives that had direct
responsibility for diversity inclusion
programs these were all global
enterprises most of them had c-level
titles or board members and they're all
across the globe and as you can see here
when asked the question sent to which
they agree that a diverse and inclusive
workforce is crucial to encouraging
different perspectives and ideas that
drive innovation 85% agree with that so
you know in general that seems to be the
consensus but is that true it turns out
the decades of research say yeah maybe
not it kind of depends so this is some
work sort of a stylized graph based on
some ugly Fleming's work at Harvard and
what you can see in this graph is two
things that I think are really important
one is that as the diversity of team
members disciplines those up the value
of innovations on average goes down
which is the complete opposite of what
we tend to believe at least should be
happening but at the same time if you
look in the upper right-hand quadrant
the only time they've have breakthrough
innovations is when you have higher
levels of team diversity and that's sort
of the conundrum so on one hand you
really do have to have high levels of
diversity in order to achieve innovation
and yet oftentimes it doesn't work out
why
is this often times it is because we
don't have strong cultures of
collaboration that's really essential
for these digitally successful or those
that are transforming using digital now
they've got strong cultures of
collaboration they incentivize people
we're working across boundaries they
emphasize hiring for in developing skill
in this cross-boundary collaboration so
there's really an intentional effort to
ensure that people are able to work
across these boundaries that they can
deal with the kinds of conflicts that
that come up they can figure out how to
integrate these really different
perspectives that ultimately could
provide higher levels of innovation so
with that we'll just wrap up you know
one of the main things I want to leave
you with is that technical skills
digital literacy architecture to deliver
are all crucial to digital
transformation but so is digital culture
and some would even argue that you have
to have that as a foundation so my
definition of digital transformation or
digital transforming which I prefer is a
radical and ongoing rethinking of how an
organization employs technology people
and processes to fundamentally change
the customer experience and business
performance so with that we'll turn it
back over to Megha great thanks much Pam
this is a really important and timely
topic so I hope everyone enjoyed the
presentation today before I'm going to
move on I want to talk a little bit
about the program that's sponsoring this
webinar today as Pam noted we're living
in a time and of unprecedented change
digital technologies are continuously
disrupting the marketplace and forcing
companies to rethink the way they
operate remaining competitive over the
next decade will require much more than
just integration of new technology
and staying one step ahead of digital
disruption companies must learn how to
strategically utilize this technology
and continuously innovate which will
improve their products services and
efficiencies all in support of better
customer experience this program will
cover tools and techniques we'll which
will teach you and your team what you
need in order to thrive in today's tech
driven market registration is open
year-round and you can visit our program
website which has been posted in the QA
and under the video on the live YouTube
channel I am going to bring some of the
common questions over to Pam so the
first one ham is a lot of people asked
us very similar questions so I've moved
it into one so there's a list of a list
of industries that they want to know if
you think are going to be impacted so
I'm going to read the list and if there
are any that you want to so it's
community medicine education travel food
service hospitality social services and
local government they would like to know
if any of these you think will be
disrupted I think all of them so can you
give me each one in Melissa GaN
Community Medicine okay certainly
medicine is being heavily affected for
example there are apps that are being
developed that help for example those
going out into communities to serve
those communities and provide data so
that in those communities you actually
have the information that you need about
the people that you're serving yeah
there were several people who asked
about education rapidly yes so that's an
interesting one because we're not I
would say we're not yet seeing a real
transformation in education it's
certainly being talked about but there's
just no question um you know even if you
look at you know some of the online
offerings and webinars for example you
know what we're doing
that wasn't done five years ago but I
would put that on the lower end of
transformation and I do believe that in
education there are a multitude of ways
that we're going to see over the next 10
years to do a better job of getting
educational materials out to groups that
wouldn't otherwise have had access and
also to just educate people more
effectively so one of the other
questions that a lot of people I think I
counted seven people asked some version
of this question so there's a there's a
question around how to get teams to
embrace new technology uh-huh so if
teams or people are first of all a
little worried about what this
technology could do to their to their
job security but in general just the
reluctance to embrace new technology in
different teams they were wondering if
you had any thoughts or or advice on how
to get people motivated to embrace it
mm-hmm
yeah you know one of the things that has
been found in looking at organizations
that are more successful a digitally
transforming and this has also been
who's been true throughout the decades
if you look at what organizations are
making dramatic changes it's often when
there's a sense of urgency you know it's
it's when it's clear that if you don't
change then you're really gonna have a
problem with job security right
so part of it is really helping people
to see what the urgency is in the
industry and what you're operating and
the challenge here is that you know if
you let's look at at Airbnb for example
or let's look at uber you know the taxi
industry had no idea that that was
coming right it's just boom it's all of
a sudden there and people aren't
prepared same thing with the hospitality
industry and Airbnb and that makes it
hard to create this sense of urgency
because you don't necessarily see you
know this slow-moving wave the
coming toward you so the challenge I
think is really helping people to see
how the destruction has happened in
other industries and the ways it could
potentially impact the work that they
are doing and the business that you're
in
so urgency I think is absolutely crucial
and the other is oftentimes you know
when people resist it's oftentimes
because we're afraid we're afraid that
we don't know how to do this new thing
we are afraid that we are going to fail
and we're going to be punished for it we
are you know we are also potentially
afraid that you know this is a trend and
we can wait so if we wait that'll be a
better strategy so creating an
environment where people feel like they
can take time to learn to try out to get
better at doing what it is it's required
is really important so creating a safe
environment in which people can develop
the skills that they need oftentimes
will help them to overcome that barrier
it's great so one other question that's
kind of related was do you think in your
you know your opinion it would be better
to outsource innovation to affirm and
then bring it in as more of a directive
so outsourcing a solution and then
giving that solution to the teams to to
execute it really depends on the
organization it depends on the industry
so in some cases so that one of the
ideas that is out there when we talk
about organizations and how you manage
innovation and also continue to do what
you do
historically as an organization this
idea of exploration
exploitation and exploitation is really
all about getting value out what you've
already got so you had some innovation
you've got some great products and
services and so forth and you want to
continue to get value out of those so
you want to exploit those and often
that's really about standard operating
procedures routines doing things the way
that they have been done so that you can
be efficient about it for exploitation
or it for exploration that's really
about innovation experimentation and
oftentimes the users require really
different cultures so part of what's
behind that question is well we don't
have a culture of innovation who've
really got an exploitation culture how
can we do the innovation one option is
to outsource the downside of that is
that you never developed the capability
within so on an ongoing basis you know
again we're not talking about just this
one transformation we're talking about
creating an organization that can
continually take advantage of these
shifts so one thing that can be done is
you can set up your organization so that
you've got some pockets that are
exploiting and some pockets that are
exploring and that way you can build the
capability within your organization by
having a separate culture in a sense but
also continue to exploit those those
products and then you can move the
things that you develop into the part of
the organization that's just really good
at the routine and standing that
standard operating procedures that's
great thanks thanks so much Pam I know
we had so many questions and this will
be this will be sent out as a recording
so people can review and unfortunately
we're getting close to the hour so we
will have to wrap up the QA but I want
to thank him so much for this and
using webinar and as I said before we
have posted the link to the certificate
page both in the tune a section of the
zoom as well as on the YouTube channel
so everyone please feel free to to check
those out and you'll see that there are
many courses that will be coming live in
the coming months we're incredibly
excited about this new program and thank
you again so much Pam and hopefully you
talk with everyone soon
you